in the middle of one of the richest
cities on earth the scale of Skid Row
can take the breath away
five thousand homeless people living in
less than a square mile in downtown Los
Angeles block after block of a
shantytown that keeps on growing where
do they go under a stay at home order
and how do you stop the spread of a
virus here
even those who can find shelter aren't
safe and the Union rescue mission is now
fighting its own outbreak of coronavirus
in the course of the last seven days we
went from six to seventy positive cases
now it's the most humbling difficult
experience of my life
Kovan 19 is ferocious mysterious monster
as we fight this valiant effort to
battle this we can only do it if we work
together in a courtyard a unit that used
to house 200 homeless women is now an
isolation unit for those who tested
positive for coronavirus officials here
have half the number of people staying
in the shelter to those like Farris
three years on the street here it is
unnerving to be truthful I'm scared that
I don't wanna I don't want to catch that
and I'm 66 years old and I really don't
know what happened to me if I do it's
outside though the doctors who bring
treatment to the streets say the virus
could run rampant there's a few thousand
people in a very small area and they can
Bop into shelters and soup kitchens at
different times and if you were to
contact trace then they might contact
trace to thousands of people in one day
for them I'm very very concerned and
we've seen outbreaks already on Skid Row
the rest of the world is saying stay
safe stay at home and they don't have a
home so they feel completely exposed
some of the most vulnerable of Skid Row
have now been moved into vacant hotel
rooms thousands of them and at the beach
rows of campervans have been brought in
to provide temporary shelter but
homeless encampments are a feature
across this city springing up even in
the wealthiest of neighborhoods half of
all of America's unsheltered homeless
live in California the authorities have
spent years trying to clear away these
tents from the streets of Los Angeles
but like so many things Cove in nineteen
is making them reassess to think again
about how best to help those most in
need behind the railings the first
official tent city in Los Angeles for 40
years built for homeless military
veterans an effort to reach some of the
most vulnerable when many of them simply
have nowhere else to go
Gregg Milam Sky News Los Angeles